تبادل الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
الاتهامات بخرق هدنه من ثلاثه ايام كان
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطون بلينكن قد
اعلنت توصل الطرفين لاتفاقا بشان الالتزام
بها وتندرج الخطوه الهشه ضمن مساء
في البلاد صدرت عن دول بينها اسرائيل كان
هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه
مسارات ما هي فرص الهدنه الامريكيه في
التحول الى اساس لوقف مستدام للقتال في
السودان كيف نقرا تعامل واشنطن مع اعلان
الخارجيه الاسرائيليه طرح مبادره لانهاء
الازمه في السودان الى اين تتطور مواقف
واطراف الازمه السودانيه في تعاملها مع
هذه التحركه
[موسيقى]
دخلنا في الهدنه الرابعه كل الهدن التي تم
اختبارها لم تصمت امام تجدد القتال مسيره
المعارك والحق هي التي تفرض منطقها العام
على الارض في ظل الاستقطاب في ظل حاله
الاستفزاز في ظل التحشيد والتحشيد المقابل
الان قوات الدعم السريع في حاله من
الانهاك وهي مشتته في الاحياء السكنيه
وبالتالي ليست لديها تواصل مع قيادتها ولا
يمكن ان تلتزم بهدنه
هذه المره تختلف اختلافا كبيرا عن
السابقاتها هناك اراده حقيقيه من قبل
الاطراف التي اعترضت هناك
جدا كانت تظن بانها يمكن ان تحقق مكاتب
وفشلت فشلا ذريعه من خلال الايام الماضيه
من
تحقيق وبالتالي ليس لديها خيار غير انحناء
للعاصفه اي مبادره تطرح هذا السياق في
حاجه الى ثلاثه على الاقل الامر الاول
المتعلق بطرح سياسي من اجل معالجه اصل
الازمه وجدر الازمه من ناحيه الامر الثاني
هو وجود ما يطلق عليه العصا والجزره يعني
هناك ان يكون في امكانيه للضغط وادوات وان
يبقى قيل هذه المبادره كي تؤتي ثمارها
الامر متعلق بامكانيه وجود نوع من الاجماع
الاقليمي والدولي على هذه المبادره
بطبيعه الحال القوات المسلحه السودانيه
عندها علاقه مع اسرائيل وكذلك قوات الدعم
السريعين ده علاقه مع اسرائيل وكل طرف
حاول انه يطور علاقه مختلفه ولكن عموما
اسرائيل دائما تحاول ان تستثمر في ازمات
السودان ولم تقف اي موقف ايجابي لصالح
السوداني الذي
فقط تحويل
الازمه السودانيه
اني بعد ان فشل منطق القوه هناك اتجاه
واحد يمكن اتجاه نحوه وهو الحوار السياسي
الذي يعني انقطع لابد ان نضع الاطار
المبادره الاسرائيليه في اطار امرين
رئيسين الامر رمزي اسرائيل تصطاد في الماء
العاكر تحاول ان تستغل الازمات الدوليه
والاقليميه من اجله اعتبرها بسيط بين
اطراف المتصارعه المتحاربه على الطرف
الاخرى الطرفين المهمين فدى الاطار
الاقليميين الامارات من جهه ومصر من جهه
اخرى لمحمدتي مصر وبالتالي هناك تعاون
اسرائيل على استغلال نفوز هذا الامارات
ومصر من اجل الدفع باتجاه نوع من الحل قد
يكون الدائم لهذا الصراع هل تنجح في ذلك
ام لا هذا سؤال الوقت يجب ان تنتظر حتى
نرى عنه هذا التحرك الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]